what's his body like on a scale from
Charles to Terry sorry buddy
what I'm the 10. sure you are Captain
Hook I need a
what's going on my doctor said I should
be more active but my squash Club
recently transitioned to racquetball
since I'm not a dope smoking hooligan I
decided to quit boy let's teach me yoga
Genevieve got me into it you can't
believe how many different ways I can
wrap my legs around her six Captain if
you wanted to be healthier why not come
to me I'm ripped as hell Sarge health is
about flexibility and peace of mind and
Bone strength not building vanity
muscles vanity muscles I use all of
these really even the large neck ones
they help me sleep upright on airplanes
well there's no reason to be defensive
just because you don't have the bone
strength of a yogi we all have our thing
you're a musler I'm a boner
Terry can do yoga Terry is a yoga Beast
watch give me a yoga to do uh well we're
in warrior pose now but I suppose for
you we can start in child's pose Harry
is not a child Siri is a warrior
and
that didn't sound good are you okay
Jeffords
I'm fine
excuse me I'm going to walk out of here
normally using my trademark Tiny Steps
okay
seven
yeah baby I can pick up the crib right
after I get the groceries and before I
start painting the nursery
it can draw clouds I don't need a
stencil okay I'll get the stencil look I
don't know when I'll be home I'll text
you okay
oh
all this paperwork is going to straight
up kill me
how are you so chipper oh simple I ate a
cacao nib every time I close a case a
what a cacao nib
they're these happy little chocolaty
Delights from deep in the Peruvian
rainforest and try one do I look like a
man who snacks you look like eight
circles with suspenders on
these aren't bad for you they're full of
fiber and antioxidants go ahead
Charlotte
okay fine just one
damn these are good plus you're organic
and fair trade
Terry loves responsible agricultural
practices
Terry I've seen this before problems at
home so you stay late at the job but
that only makes it worse everything's
great with my wife it's just my
brother-in-law's in town and we do not
get along
he thinks I'm a weakling you
let me get that for you I can do it
tiny Terry loves his pickles
he makes me feel so small who cares what
he thinks your place Sergeant you're a
grown man
now take a nap and if I see the lights
on in here I'm going to be very
disappointed in you
Sergeant is there any way you can
replace this large ball with a chair
that is actually a chair
I'm sorry sir that's all I've got but
it's good for your core yes my core it's
engaged I wouldn't take fitness tips
from this shrimp
Case Closed what time is it that's right
it's never clock
oh a new case new nib
red 20 words that's a new I think it was
kind of small hey Sarge you may want to
slow down on those things things
these are the precious jewels of the
rainforest boy I don't mean to overstep
here but you're looking a little
fat
oh boy
how dare you
you can't comment on my body this is a
workplace now I'm Feeling objectified by
your male gaze absolutely not sure just
listen No I don't want to listen Boyle
you are trying to shame me and that will
not fly okay
okay I need some more nibs just to calm
down
Sergeant you were in the 18 with me
though you were significantly
fatter sir they called me Terry titties
because I had large titties yes I
remember I never liked that nickname
though to be fair it was accurate how's
cold turkey going uh-huh
I heard chewing gum helps you know I
never smoked but I did once have an
addiction
food
it got bad
you're not close it's six o'clock I need
my musu part
I thought you should know I heard what
you said and it really sank yeah
the news really
I put my mind to something I do it
my resting heart rate is six six spoiled
you know the rest of you can learn a
little something from me sure sometimes
we fall down
but it's how we get back up that matters
we need to look our failings in the eye
and say not today
not today nibs
oh Sergeants
fine I'm not better
just too damn Delicious I don't think
the nibs being too yummy is the problem
I think right now there's too much on
your plate metaphor intended you're
stress eating that's even worse
isn't going anywhere I'm about to have
my third kid and they just get more
stressful over time man oh nibs what am
I gonna do
help me
first
I uh I know you have every right to be
stressed out new kid on the way Sharon's
on bed rest global warming this Preamble
is making me nibby
what a point I got the squad to
volunteer a little bit of their off time
to help you and your family house
I'll make dinner once a week everybody
else volunteered babysitting time and
Hitchcock offered massage sessions for
your wife what so I pepper sprayed them
you're a good man child how can I ever
thank you start taking care of yourself
again
I miss those gross overly large muscles
lay off my body dude I clearly got some
stuff to work through maybe you went up
the wall like this
oh
never mind it's not possible sure
damn Rosa how did you do that I have a
dark past
[Music]
you know my deepest shame cool well now
that I saw you do it I get how to do it
too
oh damn Terry
[Music]
I swear you've been all day yeah just
looking for Clues pretty sweaty so
everyone's hot
Terry runs on trying to see if you can
do that wall climb aren't you yeah
and I can't
I'm old because you can't parkour up a
wall it's everything the TV's always too
quiet I don't like how baggy basketball
shorts are I even shook my business some
skateboarders the other day and that's
something worse
way way worse
[Music]
hearing these reading glasses it's that
bad sorry yes it is
man
I'm his dad
his dumb wheat getting shot at the Opera
dad
what'd you eaten there Serge Cream of
Wheat it's easy to chew it it keeps you
regular it's a favorite dish of the
elderly stop freaking out about this
yeah yo I'm young at heart no you are
super old at heart you always have been
you love yogurt you volunteer at your
polling place you refuse to deposit your
checks at an ATM it's a machine I don't
trust it I get what you're saying but at
least I used to be a prime physical
specimen dude you have like one percent
body fat now I'm at 1.8 I'm fat I'm a
fat bald old man you shave your head
yeah Rosa Vin Diesel is a nice shave our
heads because we think it looks good